[Music]
now as i explained
earlier today um
white has several ways to respond to the
karaoke on white can play the advanced
which is e5 much like in the french or
white can protect this pawn
in one of several ways knight c3 or even
f3
two birds decides to take on d5 which is
the introduction to
several different systems this is called
the exchange caro
chess player is known for their
originality white can also play the move
c4 that's the pawn of attack i'll talk
about it after the game
so bishop d3 is correct because it
prevents my bishop from coming out to f5
and
if you guys have been very attentive to
the run
you will remember that i did have one
game
in this system and in that
game and this was my five minute speed
run i
kind of showed the way the black should
develop species here now we begin by
developing our knights
we develop our knights which is not
surprising
but who can tell me what we do with this
bishop
assuming yeah 92 who can well 92 is
actually not how my
first opponent played there is a certain
problem
that um that we are experiencing here
the problem and i want you guys to
listen very carefully is connected with
this bishop on
ca now we need to develop both of our
bishops right so if we go
e6 the problem with e6 as you guys
should be able to see is that it
obstructs the development of this light
squared bishop we don't want that
we can play g6 but the drawback of that
is that this bishop is going to be
biting on granite
so ideally we would want this bishop to
be on d6
but we also don't want this bishop to be
obstructed
so here's what we do we go bishop g4 but
we don't play this move
in order to pin the knight that's not
really the point the point is actually
to drop the bishop
back potentially eventually to g6 and to
trade it off
for white's light squared bishop that
trait is beneficial to black now we can
go e6
and we can safely develop this bishop
safe in the safe in the knowledge
that this bishop is eventually going to
land on g6 work is trading a favorable
trade
why is it favorable because this bishop
is not great there's a lot of pawns on
the dark squares
white tries to exploit the fact that i
haven't castled you we have to be very
careful
um we need to defend this pawn
very cautiously if we do it with the
queen he might have bishop f4 with tempo
so we're actually going to defend it
with the rook
and how are we going to meet bishop f4
which seems like a very scary move but
if you have been paying attention to how
i described our development
bishop f4 is simply met with bishop d6
and the trade of dark squared bishops is
not
is not great for us but at the same time
we get our queen onto a nice square and
then white's queen ends up being
misplaced
so to remind you we go bishop h5 with
the intention of ultimately going bishop
g6
we go bishop g6 we get rid of our dark
light square bishop now
this leads to a very interesting
situation because
we have not castled yet and most people
would consider that a bad thing right
you want to castle as quickly as
possible but that could be a good thing
now who can explain to me why after
he takes on g6 and we take back
why is the fact that we haven't castled
potentially
a good thing
so we actually might end up not castling
at all
we leave the rook on the h-file and this
pawn represents a hook
we can later push the jeep on using it
as a battering ram
trying to get rid of this h-pawn and
orchestrating a very quick
king-side attack in terms of this king
one very five head idea is to compromise
i call this a compromise castle
we don't want to keep the king on the e
file because it's very easy to get to
the king so we could tuck it away on the
f
file so let's play bishop d6 let's try
to make him take
uh on g6 we can tuck the king on the
f-file
which to an untrained eye seems so weird
like why aren't you castling
the point of king f8 is we find this
sort of shelter for the king this
you know not ideal but relatively robust
shelter and we do that because we are
fully banking on getting that quick
attack to work
now in in not taking on g6 my opponent
has made a big mistake
he has not factored in the type 1 and
type 2 undefended pieces i remind you
type 2 undefended piece is a piece that
is protected
by only one other piece those need to be
monitored
okay when you don't monitor them you
miss stuff and that's exactly what
happens here this bishop on d3
it's a standoff standoffs are also very
dangerous
this bishop is protected by the knight
we can slice off
its defender and then white is well
bishop takes g6 is what he what he
wanted to do but obviously here
we don't take the bishop we take the
other bishop take the other bishop
and we are going to be up a piece to add
insult to injury we're attacking the
night now what should white do here okay
he correctly played bishop f7
before you guys could answer he's
already losing a piece so he might as
well
give the piece up for a pawn now
mistakes very often happen in the
immediate moments after you win a piece
or after you win material
because you take your foot off the gas
pedal you relax let's not do that
let's try to solve the one remaining
problem in our position which is the
problem of our king
we want to ensure safety for this king
so we want the king on g8 but
could somebody explain to me why the
immediate king g8 is bad
and then how we uh castle by hand
as this technique is called we don't
literally castle you guys are all
indicating this
very good king g8 traps the rook so the
solution to this
is rook f8 followed by king g8 he can't
do anything to us
uh straight away so we can keep the king
on f7 for one more move
if he had a pawn on g4 for instance
then um we would not have been able to
afford
the luxury of doing this but here we can
and now our king is perfectly safe the
fact that he's double on the file is not
scary in fact we can repurpose that to
our
advantage uh because later we might be
able to force a trade down the file
okay um let's solve the problem
of this rook being tied down so there's
a couple of things i don't like about my
position
and in order to win it we're not going
to do everything in one move
we need to solve you know each problem
step one step at a time and we're going
to gradually untangle
and then we're going to win in one of
several ways now first of all
um let's list the things we want to do
we want to connect the rooks
uh the screen on d8 could be doing a lot
more than it's doing
uh i spy a nice square on d6
but i also spy an even nicer square
where the queen is not only
in the center or near the center but it
can fulfill another role remember
you want your pieces to be fulfilling as
many roles as
they can be without getting overwhelmed
so
this pawn on b7 what i don't like about
this situation is that the circumvie
is tied down to the pawn it is
it is a servant to the pawn and
we don't want that to be the case we
want to be we want the rook to be able
to go to the center
if necessary and so we can deploy our
queen to add a secondary layer of
protection to the pawn
now what i want to emphasize here does
that mean we are going to
play rook beat on the next move not
necessarily but we just want to be able
to
should the situation change why is this
better than queen esa well queen e7 just
visually
controls less squares queen on e7 is
sort of
uh you know roofed by the pawn whereas
the queen on c7 controls this diagonal
just controls more squares
so b6 is also possible but it leaves the
knight undefended i'm nitpicking here
but
i don't like creating undefended pieces
when i don't have to
now who could propose for me a plan of
action in this position
how do we continue nurturing our
advantage
yes potato pateo for president very nice
i like the idea of doubling rooks on the
file
i love the idea of doubling rooks on the
f file
and um the reason i love that is
obviously because later on we could
trade all four rooks down the f
do we need to react to this no we can
just continue if he takes we take no
problem
and that is the ultimate and by the way
uh
gaines notice that if our pawn was on b6
then we would have had to worry about
him taking on d5 because then that
knight
which would have been undefended could
have been subjected to an attack
like rook c1 okay so now we've made
basically all of the necessary
improvements to our position
it is time to transform our position
into something concrete we are up a
piece but
that's not gonna win us the game we have
to actually do some work
now how can we do some work there are
several ways to play here there's many
many alternatives um now knight a5
is a good thought to attack this pawn
but he could play b3 i'm not sure where
that is going
um instead i'm going to propose for you
guys a
different approach and let me actually
calculate this for a second
the approach that i'm going to propose
involves
improving the situation of the queen the
queen on c7
is good but it could be even better on
which square
could it be really pounding on white's
weaknesses
and i'm going to show you guys what the
ultimate idea is it's it's not too
this this next move is a transitory
point yes queen g3
now the fact that it's attacking the
pawn is nice but you guys might be
looking at this and saying hmm
um great daniel what about rook f3 just
chasing the queen away what the hell is
the point of this
well the point of this is to transfer
the queen over to the king side
which has two effects first of all we
can offer a queen trade which has been
which is beneficial to us we're up a
piece second of all
by moving the queen to g6 when we move
our knight away from f6 we are going to
be a lot better equipped
to deal with the standoff on the f-file
if our queen is on the king side
that should just make sense to you guys
logically when our queen is this close
to the king side
i would feel a lot more comfortable
moving my knight away and essentially
forcing
a mass trade of rooks down the f file
which is going to create
an end game where we are simply up a
piece hopefully
that makes a certain degree of sense in
addition we bring the e4 square under
better control
which means that 94 as you guys are
pointing out is will now be on the cards
whereas here
94 would lose another pawn it would it
might trade rooks but it would lose a
second pawn
takes takes and takes so
does this make sense i mean i've tried
to guide you guys through the logic okay
knight f3
is a logical reaction but a
further mistake as usual we need to
notice that this queen is very strong
we need to ask ourselves what the
drawbacks are of white's previous move
you guys are pointing out and this is
something you should see
given our reasoning 94 is incredibly
strong it opens up
massive pressure down the f-file he is
in a
irresolvable dilemma if he doesn't move
his work we take it if he does
then we take the knight using the pin
the game is essentially over we're going
to be up a rook at the very least
or two pieces yeah the night pair
yeah the queen and knight tandem is so
fearsome look how all of our pieces are
very well coordinated
that's the result of playing
methodically and playing carefully and
openings like the karaoke promote this
kind of
thing which is why i recommend it to a
lot of players when you play the karakan
you
put yourself in a position where you can
really work on your ability to
to you know to master peace placement to
master
uh methodical positional play it might
not be that flashy
i might not be sacking my queen every
game but hey
uh you got to do that grunt work if you
want to be good
if you want to have games where you all
pawns and no hopes that benny watts but
i might have something to say about that
benny
okay two birds good game thanks again
yeah i think he probably will resign
appreciate hearing that falgus and
this is all possible thanks to
everybody's support this literally gives
me energy
and i try to transform that energy into
the best instruction that i can provide
and i try to keep getting better so
please feel free to
supply constructive criticism i try to
incorporate it
uh if you have opening requests i cannot
guarantee
accommodating it just take back nothing
has changed as a result of this trade
but i will do my best
okay
dania is just my name that just means
danny and russian
okay um he's thinking now but it's too
little and too late
yeah i mean look at just look at the the
pressure that's that's on his position
so in order not to waste time while he's
thinking
uh just a couple of things uh
the alternate method of developing and
this is going to be really we're really
going to delve into the weeds here
but um i want to show you guys how
i think about these opening nuances and
i want to show you guys that you are
capable
more capable than you think perhaps uh
not to put words in anybody's mouth but
more capable than some people realize
of understanding openings at a very deep
level
even if you don't play them so i had
mentioned okay so he makes a move we're
going to take the knight of course he
can't take because of the pin
i mentioned when he played the the
exchange
oh my battery is low on my headphones uh
um
i mentioned when i played this that i
that i had a previous game in the speed
and let us find that game and i will
show you guys that game
that game features a slightly different
way
of solving the problem of the bishop
development that i had highlighted
in this position uh but there was one
key difference
that that guided me toward choosing that
other
method and we're going to do a little
bit of detective work you guys are going
to put on your sherlock holmes hats
and you are going to tell me why i chose
that particular method of development in
that game
and why i chose to deviate in this game
okay so get ready for a little detective
work guys
um okay two words i think
resigning might be a good option here
down two nights no compensation
i have no one to tell anybody to resign
but
i think i'm going to tell you to resign
yeah there's
there are some ideas here with maybe a
queen sack here there but
yeah i don't really see even a way to
make this pretty white is
nothing i mean the white cannot even
make a threat queen b3 maybe
but then the rook can just drop back to
f5 a million moves
he probably muted the stream yeah he
goes queen b3 so we have to be a little
bit careful here oh actually
let me think he is being a good guy in
that stream slime i appreciate that
i'm trying to find something cool for
you guys
yeah there isn't much here
yeah there's not i'm trying to find some
sort of a pretty win
but the reality is we should keep things
relatively mundane here actually we need
to be careful
we need to be careful uh because the
move rook f5 that i had previously
mentioned
it does run into queen takes b7
so rook f2 is perhaps the most direct
but then he plays queen takes d5 and if
we play king h8
he plays queen takes e4 and he threatens
backrank mate
so we actually do need to be very
careful here
more careful perhaps than it might
appear
the simplest and when you're stuck in a
situation like this you're like oh my
god
you know all of a sudden you realize
things are not
as clear as you thought they were it's
okay what you want to do
is just bring back the defenders solve
the immediate problem what is the
immediate problem here
work with me here the immediate problem
is not that he's threatening this pawn
it is that he's threatening this pawn
with check the fact of the matter is
we're up two knights we can afford to
give up a pawn
so the fact that he's threatening this
pawn with check is the problem
because then he's gonna win this knight
so the move that i advocate here is rook
back to f7 we are simply taking the
sting out of this move after he takes on
d5 it is no longer check
which means we have time to move the
knight to a place of our choosing
i see this happen a lot at all levels
particularly 16 1700 level i have
students
who have had this as a weakness they'll
be winning
then their opponent will make a move
that one could
classify as nasty some sort of a nasty
defensive idea
and what happens is panic yeah knight g5
knight h3 is very pretty
um panic ensues immediately but
um when your opponent makes one of those
unexpected moves you have to go down to
the root
of what it is that makes the move nasty
and there it's very important to be very
precise
right it's not the fact that it's the
pawn it's the fact that it's
a check uh same thing with the b7 pawn
when he takes on b7
uh that's not the problem the problem is
that this rook on f3
is potentially hanging if we move the
queen away from
from g3 so we solve all of these
problems at once
yeah knight g5 is i think the best
because
notice that the knight covers d8 now
knight takes h3 is a huge threat
and the game comes quickly to an end
okay so what was i going to
do okay i'm going to find
this game i'm going to find this game
this game was actually quite recent so
it will not take me very long to find
i think no it was not this game one
second as
he's thinking
yes there it is okay knight takes h3 by
the way
is a very nice move because if he takes
have i blundered
what is the idea guys what if he just
takes the knight whoa whoa whoa
what if he just takes the knight what
are we doing
well then queen takes h3 and not rook
off one
the rook is spin guys rook is spins
folks rook is pinned
jack squared if the rook wasn't pinned
we would have gone rook f1 immediately
we didn't need to take on h3
the fact is we go queen to f1 no problem
it happens queen to f1 is the idea
because while the rook is spinned it can
still control a square
so the king will not be able to take the
queen
we are going to win the i mean if rook
h2 then it's mate otherwise we win the
rook
and uh on defended pieces again loose
pieces drop off
how did i see this move how did i know
to check for knight takes h3 well i know
that when the king is confined
to close quarters then there are two
main types of tactics the first is of
course checkmate
but the second is actually and this is
very underestimated is and i'm just
going to trade queens here that's the
simplest is uh forking
forking the king in another piece uh
because like the king is a walking
forkable machine
when it's very vulnerable okay two birds
i think i think now is a good time to
resign thank you woozy meow to your one
okay um we're just going to try to mate
him here
i'm not sure why time is being spent but
it's fine it's his
his prerogative
yeah obviously we don't need to worry
about stalemate right now
because because he's got a pawn move
the worst thing to do here would be to
take this pawn um
a little life hack for
a little life [ __ ] no i applaud him for
fighting oh no problem little life hack
for
like bullet games where you're trying to
avoid stalemate leave your opponent with
a pawn
in that case you can make a move like
this safe in the knowledge that it is
not going to be stalemate
what i see a lot of people do is they
try to take all of their opponents pawns
and then they open themselves up for
some sort of stalemate down the line if
you're not
too worried about flagging leave your
opponent with a pawn that way you don't
have to actually
manually check for stale made in most
cases good game
now before we do anything let me show
you that other game that i played
and that other game was a karo khan by
transposition
it actually started off as a london but
because of the way that we played
it ended up being an exchange caro by
transposition
now i want you guys to look at this game
uh
carefully for a second so here i play
the alternate way
of solving the problem of these two
bishops i fianchetto the bishop
and could somebody let me know what is
the drawback and i
mentioned this what is the drawback
thank you super it's what is the
drawback of
enchanting the bishop uh the the the
main drawback
it's biting on granite right it's it's
just staring at this pawn which is not a
tragedy i mean the bishop is okay it
could potentially support an e5 pawn
right but it's not great
but here there is a very important move
bishop f5 and this is the reason why i
played g6
the secondary purpose of g6 in this case
is to actually prepare this move
and as i explained during that speedrun
game it may appear that i'm ruining my
pawn structure on the king's side
but the reality is i'm doing exactly the
opposite i am creating for myself
a huge stronghold on e4 for my knight
and i'm opening up the g file where i
later
put a rook and basically checkmated him
on that file
so appearances are very deceptive here
we go everything happens on that g file
i literally
double up on the g file and then i slam
him down with queen takes h3
and he resigned in this position because
bishop f4 is coming in
there's more to talk about here but this
will be on youtube ultimately
so this seems like a pretty good
strategy this is what's actually
recommended in most books
against this particular version of the
exchange carl now let's go back to the
game against two words
two words plays this a little bit
differently right in in the other game
the knight was on f3
uber plays a move knight to e2 so why
is it that i did not do the same thing
why don't i go g6 and bishop g7 and
castle and then bishop f5 same exact
thing right i'm gonna get my knight to
e4 and i'm gonna
i'm gonna mess him up here what's the
difference
this is a small exercise in detecting
small
differences you i mean i'm actually i'm
legitimately impressed right now i'm
legit you guys all deserve subs i'm
legitimately impressed
uh because people are seeing the fact
that the f pawn
is now free why is that important that
is important because we can
bring under the control the e4 square so
knight e4
is no longer possible that is black's
main attack moves that sets everything
in motion
if 94 is impossible this knight is kept
at bay
and this falls kind black can play this
but this falls flat
as others are pointing out in addition
knight g3
uh oh my god i did not mean to bait
stuff gifters but i just did his
game strain with 20. damn girl
oh my lands and my headphones died let
me
put my other ones on holy smokes gains
you kidding me 20 gifted amazing
well they just all got subs and i
did not mean to bait anybody but thank
you gaines you are
the freaking man that is
some crazy stuff right there thank you
so much i appreciate it
you are will make it amazing okay
um so f3 and this falls flat so that's
the reason why
here i played bishop g4 safe in the
knowledge that i'm going to eventually
bring the bishop back to g6 that bishop
is not going to be stuck in no man's
land
okay the rest was actually very simple i
mean
here knight takes g6 was probably the
best option and as i explained during
the game
in order to get the king to safety
without castling which would
defeat the purpose of what we're doing
here i.e keeping the rook
for a potential h-file attack we go king
to f8 which is sort of a a compromise
right a compromise or even king to g8
because
whereas making this move in
um in this position
would be horrible because the rook would
be locked out the key difference is that
the rook is
actually controlling that h file which
is why we could go here
um so that's what we would have done
no two birds was honorable now this is
uh unfortunately a blunder
after this move white is just lost now
how specifically would we have well king
d7 is
the problem with king d7 is that brings
the king closer to
the center which would allow a move such
as c4
and uh that would potentially open up
the center and the king could get caught
on the crossfire
king fade is just safer uh by most
intuitive measures
how specifically would we have conducted
this attack
well there are several things we could
build up a battery
and one advantage of this battery is
that g3 is met with rook takes h3
and then potentially rook takes g3 and
you know check make it happen very very
quickly in these positions uh this has
tremendous potency so white has to play
this
very weakening move f4 and how do we
target this f pawn what is a good way
much like i
explained we can do with the h3 pawn we
can do the same thing this is also a
hook
yeah so gains i'll tackle that in a
second yeah g5 is right
he doesn't have to take but we put a lot
of pressure on it so the thing is
gains the good thing about this pawn
configuration these double pawns
is i'm not banking on the use of both
pawns
to attack h3 forget about the pawn on g7
if it didn't exist right we would only
have one jeep on
so this is the pawn that i'm going to
use uh
to as the battering round the g7 pawn is
like extra credit
that pawn is providing shelter to the
king and ensuring that even if let's say
that
attack fails we're gonna have we're
gonna shed the skin
you know um and we're gonna molt
but at the end we're still going to have
a nice cover for the king so if worse
comes to worst
we have this insurance policy provided
by this other g pawn
that's why i always encourage people to
rethink their attitude toward doubled
pawns
double pawns can be freaking fantastic
one pun could be providing shelter the
other could be used as an attacker
that's what it is here i don't want to
over overstate the case here black is
not winning
it's actually hard to play g5 because
the bishop is controlling that square
uh white is not worse white is probably
better according to the computer
but that's completely beside the point
i'm trying to indicate
concepts here rather than specific
positions necessarily
um that doesn't mean you want to get
doubled pawns
um in every game oh daniel told me
you know double bonds were good not
always double puns can be horrible
but i encourage people to just try to be
concrete
look at it on a case-by-case basis
okay so that would be my
my advice any questions about this game
once we won the extra piece
excuse me the rest was i think explained
during the game i mean
we didn't do anything extraordinary
queen g3 and queen g6
and actually queen g3 rook after we
would we would have gone queen g6 that
was the idea
when he went queen b3 why not knight f6
instead of the rook move yes
so again um
oh when he went queen b3 for the second
time i assume
soon or where oh queen b3 in the opening
right
oh the end okay oh here okay sorry
yeah knight f6 is possible but but i
didn't want to give this pawn up and the
problem is the rook
doesn't have a way back so the king
the king can get caught in the crossfire
here i don't like the fact that the rook
is on f3
uh because the queen is burdened very
heavily and neither do you karissa
yeah but now i have energy all of a
sudden i feel i don't feel like i want
to collapse
into bed um so again
none of these decisions were like
crucial to the point where
they were only moves but i'm just trying
to give you guys one way to think about
the position what about knight takes d4
where here i don't understand now it
just takes
oh you mean here ah but now queen takes
d5
see that's exactly what i pointed out
guys that's why i played workouts so
that this move doesn't come with check
right the fact is queen takes d5 isn't
the scary part it's queen takes d5
check that's the scary part and you're
gonna lose
one of these knights so we wanted to
take the sting out of the
disease not the symptoms
okay